It's the left and you talking about true evil.
When you work diligently to keep people hopeless and educated.
That's what I call evil.
You go to the state of California with 75% of the Blackboard state of
California. 2017 can not pass standard reading and writing tests.
When young people cannot read and write,
we're not going to talk about space court.
We're not going to have conversations like this.
You're going to turn on the networks and be driven by emotion because they have
no hope, no way of thinking. No matter reasoning.
What kind of traction are you getting? Cause you know,
it's funny the way Twitter operates, you know,
I see certain personalities that are,
will bubble up for awhile and then I'll click a profile. I'll go, Oh,
this guy is running for Congress in Utah.
This girl's running for something in Florida, something else. And you're,
you're kind of like, Oh,
well they they're sort of popular on Twitter or they make sense here,
but it's a little hard to tell from as an outsider. Well,
is this gaining traction at home?
How can you grade sort of where your campaign is at? Uh, are,
are there weak spots that you want to shore up? You know, that kind of thing.
Very different.
I think the blessings that I've had is that I never thought about being a
politician all these years. I mean,
literally it did not happen until by this time last year.
So up until this point, I came out of the book. Uh, the person was, uh,
liberalism, how to turn good men into whiners, weenies, and wimps.
And that got me on just run the same time that the company gets a good title.
It really is, but it's,
it's just about the same time the company was doing his kneeling,
but had a chance to get on and share with America,
my thoughts and my pride in country and that what I saw as really being
detrimental. So I had a chance to develop some friendships throughout the time.
And so now that I, that I'm running,
I really have an opportunity to have exposure.
That's been very advantageous for me. Uh,
we have a community again because we're,
we're very conservative that looks at Fox. So many people knew me somewhat,
even though I was in a very small niche, I was working with at-risk kids.
So it wasn't out in community a whole lot, but it's been an opportunity for me.
First of all, to really know, uh, this, this,
this district a lot more than I would've ever no outstate lot better.
Cause I'm not out talking with people.
And what I'm finding is that my message resonates.
We all just want to have somebody who willing to stand and not,
not wilt and not, not feel ashamed and not apologize.
And I'll tell you to be in the end of the day when God country,
family and raised is the most important thing before anything else it's easy to
stand. It really is no big deal because if that's being attacked,
then you want to run to make sure you protect all the above.
And that's what I'm finding out across our country.
We have conservatives that really get it. They don't mind taking the hit.
They don't mind being called names. Cause it doesn't mean a thing.
Matter of fact, I tell people, call me names, make sure you're using your time.
Right? Cause it doesn't impact me.
You might be wasting a lot of time because it doesn't bother me at all. So,
so together we get that group together and we get this message to those
again, who has been truly used over the last few months,
the abuse the last few months,
I think we have a point that we can start to resonate and say, yes, you know,
guys,
this worked together to get our County back to where it was a few months ago and
this time know who the enemy is and never go back.
And I think that's where we come out of this, this process with.
Yeah. So I, as I said,
I was on your website this morning and I was looking at the issues that you
knock out one, one at a time, uh, let's just do two or three that you're,
that you're particularly passionate about. Um, you, you leave,
I'll even toss them up to you.
Give me two or two or three that you really care about that you think are the
core issues that that can help you in.
Very good, very good day. Uh, again,
everything that I'm working with is based on those promises, life, Liberty,
and pursuit of happiness.
That's the bottom line for us to understand that we have to be educated,
ignorant and free can never be Thomas Jefferson. That is so powerful.
And the left is understood that a long time.
That's why they work very hard to make sure we stay ignorant. It's the left.
And you talk about true evil.
When you work diligently to keep people hopeless and educated.
That's what I call evil.
You go to the state of California with 75% of the Blackboard state of California
in 2017 can not pass standard reading and writing tests.
When young people cannot read and write,
we're not going to talk about space Corps.
We're not going to have conversations like this.
You're going to turn on the network and be driven by emotion because they have
no hope, no way of thinking. No matter reasoning,
they'll never read the scriptures.
The connection with a God in heaven will never ever happen.
And you go to every single threshold.
Every single city that's owned by the leftist, by the Democrats.
You've seen the exact same thing, hopelessness, anger, and literacy.
So education is going to be a bit big. It's going to be a big piece.
Now the other part of education is that what they've done in higher education.
It's just not just the poor kids that are being attacked.
It's the rest of our kids.
That's how middle-class we raise our kids in a great environment.
We send them off to get a degree.
They come back as little marks as Hayden off country and not being able to think
at all about reasoning.
They have been doing this for so long and now you see it in the streets,
across the country and T4. They're not black kids. They're they're,
they're middle-class yuppie my days yuppies. What was cool?
I don't know if it's still cooler, but, but they're, they're,
they're they're kids who have the wealth, but they hate our country.
What I think we should do is very simply this I talked about earlier,
this put together a program and an understanding of what is expected about
colleges. They want, they want, they want our money. They, first of all,
we have to see transparency. How much is being been?
How much are they succeeding and what areas we need as a country,
if they don't hit those areas, those, those bills do matrix. We get our money,
we take it back, put it someplace else. So education is the first thing.
One of the things that just warmed my heart really warmed my heart.
When I saw the rise in Minneapolis, it had this video of these black owners,
black businesses just next to each other. Yeah. And in the window, black owned,
big black deck back on.
And this was an it opportunity for all of us to see what a Passover looks
because the, the, the locus and the,
the pillage of losers passed over these businesses. Why?
Because there was these eight or 15 sitting there on the store to these Gates,
these kids, knowing that it didn't show up here,
you're going to have some issues,
some issues they pass by to go to those companies.
Those businesses that still believes in the bureaucracy is going to take,
going to save them. So those,
I think those are the two top things is education educational allow us to have
that mindset to go out and build our own businesses, build our property,
which is important.
That's what the pursuit of happiness was in place for pursuit of property.
When that property will be tangible property, intellectual property,
spiritual property passed down through our kids, our name, those things.
We work our lives to build at the end of the day, without our last breath,
which was able to say, I'm so glad I live because this is my legacy.
That's what a property was truly means in order to protect that,
we need to be educated,
to think about what it looks like and to have the vision, to get there.
We also have to have the tools to protect every single step of the way so nobody
can come in and steal it from us. And we now understand,
we've talked about needing to have that, that ability go to these cities,
where they would just let loose evils, just let loose. In these cities.
We started to see what it really looks like and where we can.
We can never let that happen in our lifetime.
Do you think that that mindset of, of how to conquer all of this,
um, is really the same mindset,
whether you're an entrepreneur or a professional athlete or a politician that
really wants to change things properly, that it is purely a mindset of,
I am going to dedicate myself to this relentlessly and see it fit.
And maybe that's why you can see it as a,
as a former NFL player where some people can't quite see it because, you know,
there's this idea that somehow victimhood gives you virtue these days,
or can't someone else do it, or, or the cyst,
the rules are so against me that I can't do it. But it's like,
if we think of all of our heroes, our sports heroes or fictional heroes,
they did it. They said it doesn't matter how messed up the game is. Um,
I'm going, gonna win. I'm going to fix it.
And you know, that's, that's what comes out of a healthy environment. Uh,
that's what came out of my community growing up. Um, did your parents,
when we had the idea, first of all, life is not always called fair.
Life is difficult. And there are people who are going to try to slow you down.
But if you have the tenacity,
you can dream because you've educated yourself to know this possible.
And you have the faith know that, that you're just especially anybody else.
Then we can overcome those obstacles, the problem with having in my community.
And we're now having across the country. And I say this as often as I can,
what destroyed my community was turned it upside down.
So we see kids now that are acting like victims and it's destroying their own
properties. It was not white supremacists.
It's never has been white supremacists. We beat out white supremacists.
It's been black liters. It's been those with stealth. Those who look like me,
those who talk like me, those who put their arms around and say, you know,
we're going to bake things right. And make things.
So it's all fair and it's still out. They go and they go to Congress,
the black caucus, the NAACP, uh, your name, um,
the elitist instead of giving us and tell us what we can do.
They purposely put in place impediments.
They put in laws that make sure the poor connect become,
become melt middle class,
to make sure that our poor black kids could never be educated. Why?
Because they're stuck because of this anti-choice that these black leaders will
vote for and stand for and see their people destroyed because they
don't care. So it is truly elite as across the board. That's our enemy.
And I'll say this, if we go ahead and educate ourselves,
not to what the propaganda of the leftist educate ourselves to our history,
educate ourselves to what we, the people have done. I'll tell you, Dave,
if we did that, I'm just real quick story. I would never, ever,
ever, I'm not a racist. I've never will be, but my point is,
but particularly for, uh, uh, um,
our German and Mexican Americans will ever look down or feel bad about that
race, those people. Why? Because my, when my great,
great grandfather came here and had been the Belle of the ship, a slave ship,
they escaped, uh, North, South Carolina, uh, plantation that bridges plantation.
They went to Southern and Western route of the underground railroad guess who
was, who was making that happen? Christian,
German Americans and Mexican Americans, and opened the doors,
opening the fields, fed them, gave them hope along the way.
And what happened when that trip out West, not only did my, my great,
great grandfather understand he could make great things happen,
but he was able to forgive and went on to be a successful entrepreneur. Uh,
I owned a hundred, two acres of land that he bought in two, eight, two years,
a pillar of his community, because along the way, this traveler,
he realized that all white people on bad.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.